There's something interesting going on
within the evangelical Christian movement,
which is that, too, to some degree, prominent
evangelical Christians have started to
sort of turn on Donald Trump or at least
acknowledge that it's time to go, buddy.
90 year old extremist evangelical televangelist
leader Pat Robertson of 700 Club fame accurately
assesses the cult of personality around Donald
Trump and says it's time to move on. You really
have to see this to believe it. And there's an
interesting irony here which I'm going to discuss
discuss with you after we look at this first clip.
I think it's all over. I think the Electoral
College has spoken. I think the the Biden
corruption has not totally been brought to
fruition, but it doesn't seem to be affecting the
Electoral College. And I don't think the Supreme
Court is going to move in to do anything. And
I think we're going to see a President Biden.
And I also think we'll be seeing a President
Kamala Harris not too long after the inauguration
of President Biden. With all his talent and the
ability to raise money and draw large crowds,
the president still lives in an
alternate reality. He really does.
People say, well, he lies about this then, but no,
he doesn't lie to him. That's the truth. He had
the biggest crowd on Inauguration Day. He had he
had more people than ever. He was the most popular
of people, but he saved NBC. But with the
the Senate to go down the line of things that
really aren't true. And, you know, people kept
pointing to them, but because they loved him so
much and he was so strong for the evangelicals,
evangelicals were with him all the way. But there
was something about him that was good that God
placed him in that office for the time. He's
done a marvelous job for the economy. But at the
same time, he is very erratic. And he he's fired
people. He's for people and he's insulted people
and he keeps going down the line. So it's it's
a mixed bag. And I think it would be willing to
say you've had your day and it's time to move on.
What I love about this is that the same cult
of personality that Pat Robertson identifies as
surrounding Donald Trump, the same narcissism that
Pat Robertson identifies Trump is suffering from.
It's identical to both the followers of
evangelical cult leader types like Pat Robertson
and of the fall of the leaders themselves. We
wonder, does Trump believe he's a liar or does he
know he's lying? The cultish answer would be, you
know, eventually cult leaders become so deluded
that what may start as things they know to be
lies, they end up kind of believing their own
lies, or at least if they know they're lying, they
believe they're lying for the right reason because
the means justify the ends or they're telling some
bigger truth if they don't focus on the minutia.
These are really common thought kind of paradigms
or mental models, I think is the right term
for cultish leaders of all kinds. And when
Pat Robertson says Trump believes the lies,
I suspect that the same applies to many
evangelical cultists like Pat Robertson and
others. We've. Covered, they believe that the
world is better off when people donate to them
so that they can buy a private jet because the
private jet better allows them to go and spread
the gospel or whatever it is that that they
claim to do, they get to a point where they
have to mostly believe their own lies in order to
continue living a semi coherently on just like a
day to day practical level. But Pat Robertson
is mostly accurate in his analysis of critique
and critique of Trump. It's just that most of the
analysis would apply as accurately to himself and
to other evangelical televangelist types like
Pat Robertson. It's actually incredible, though,
that Pat Robertson would accuse others of being
in an alternate reality, because Pat Robertson is
a guy who has said that the following list of
things can be demonic. OK. Pat Robertson says
Trump's in a fantasy world. Pat Robertson has said
second hand sweater's can have demons attached.
Ouija boards can be demonic. Yoga is demonic.
Harry Potter, Feng Shui, karate, horoscopes,
the Twilight series. Actually, you know what? The
Twilight series could be demonic. But other than
that, this list is crazy. Paintings of Buddha TV
shows about ghosts, Halloween just writ large.
Psychic's young girls who do levitation during
sleepovers and sometimes even a even adopted
children from other countries can be demonic,
according to Pat Robertson. And Pat Robertson says
Trump's living in an alternate reality. What a
what a world we live in. Is it now? One other
funny thing. I didn't know until yesterday that
Pat Robertson's son is part of the grift. Gordon
Robertson, this is a new I guess this is maybe the
sort of like televangelist er to Pat Robertson,
a Gordon Robertson, who is Pat Robertson's son,
is also involved with the 700 Club. And he also
seems to have turned on Donald Trump here
as Gordon Robertson a few weeks ago, saying
he doesn't think the Trump legal team is is
making any sense with what they're doing.
I got to ask you, if they're not going to go
forward with proof in these press conferences,
shouldn't they just shut down the press
conferences? Why? Why why have them? I
I'm looking at this. It's a complete disaster for
Trump. And why is he even doing it? They have had
other press conferences. There's the famous Four
Seasons total landscaping. It just doesn't seem
it doesn't seem to be helping whenever they get in
front of the cameras. It just doesn't seem to be
helping. Again, the question is always let's see
the evidence. But without people sort of buying in
that there's evidence of widespread fraud. If you
don't have that and you have state legislatures
coming in and saying we're going to invalidate
the vote totals and vote our own slate of electors
and so that our team gets to win. Aren't
aren't you really playing with fire? I mean,
at that point in time, does anyone trust
our democracy anymore? I mean, the all the
allegations that we're looking at dictatorship,
that we're looking at overthrowing democracy,
all of those allegations come to the fore. And I
would predict you'd see rioting in the streets.
How insane is that? Pat Robertson and Gordon
Robertson both saying Trump's wacky while they
are completely wacky. Fascinating to watch. And
I my instinct is that this seeming realignment
is going to disappear very quickly and everything
will go back to where it was. Much like I said,
that Republicans are going to sort of
forget about Trump once Trump disappears and
the coup y Trump, I don't know. We're
here about we're here to lower the debt
and prevent socialism or whatever. I assume
that the evangelical televangelist types
that have started to see a little bit of reason
are going to go right back to the same stuff.
Joe Biden's very demonic and and so on.
A very quickly that's my prediction
remains to be seen whether it happens The
David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.